Speaker 1: Let's see if Chris from Baltimore
can save us. Chris, you are now on the
air. Hey, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: OK, well, that's crazy. Well,
I just wanted to ask a random question basically,
like if you had if you were the president and
you had executive order privileges. Sure, what
would be the first executive order you passed,
assuming you could only do one?
Speaker 1: I have no idea. It's
such a weird. I mean, the thing about these
questions, they're almost sort of like,
would you rather only eat avocados for the next
five years or have to do a thousand sit ups
before you could drink water each day? It's like,
I don't know. It's unlikely to ever be a scenario.
If I could, oh, I don't. I don't know
what it would be. I mean, here's the thing
if I was really going to be in the position of
getting to sign one executive order first, I would
want to be fully briefed as to all of the things
that can even be done via executive order so that
I could be informed and really evaluate like
I could just say to you, Oh, the first thing I
would do is I would forgive student debt for some
student debt or something like that. If I knew the
full scope of what a president could do via video,
I might say something completely different. So
I don't know. I'm not good at these kind of
force questions. Let me ask you a question.
If if the only breakfast you could eat
for a year was oatmeal with hot dogs in it
or apples? Which one would you go with?
Speaker 2: I see what you're trying to
say. I mean, probably the hot dog option. Wow.
Speaker 1: I see. That's crazy for me. That's
an easy question. I would go
with the apples, but okay,
that's fair. Right?
Speaker 2: David,
thank you so much. And I'm a huge man.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thanks for calling.
And there's Chris from Baltimore. Let's
take a very quick break. If you're holding,
hang on for me, we're going to go
right back to the phones in a moment.